Speaker 1: It's great to welcome to the program
today, Bill Browder, who is the CEO of Hermitage
Capital Management, head of the Global Magnitsky
Justice Campaign, and also author of the book
Red Notice.
So, Bill, to start with, the the story you
tell in your book includes, as you got into
the world of finance, your interest in Eastern
Europe, which included initially doing some
work in Poland when there was relatively little
work being done in Poland by U.S. and British
based folks in the finance world and eventually
actually going to Russia itself.
Talk a little bit about how that all worked
and how you ended up working in that part
of the world.
Speaker 4: Sure.
So I went out to Russia in 1992, just at the
beginning of the Russian privatization program,
basically when when when the Soviet Union
broke up, Russia became a sort of, quote,
democracy.
The new president wanted to go from communism
to capitalism.
And in order to do that, they basically the
state owned all the property and they said,
we're going to give all the property away
for free to the people and make them capitalists.
And and, of course, as we know, most of the
property ended up in the hands of a very small
number of Russian oligarchs.
But there were little crumbs falling off the
table.
And those crumbs were shares of some of the
biggest Russian companies which are trading
on the stock market.
And I went and set up a business called the
Hermitage Fund to basically pick up those
crumbs and invest in the newly privatized
companies.
And for a while, it was just a bonanza, like
bigger profits, I guess, you know, made cryptocurrency
gains look like child's play was just so the
returns were so great.
Speaker 1: So you eventually got involved
in this space where there was the possibility
of investing in Russian companies at massive
discounts from what traditional finance measures
would assess as the value of these companies.
Talk a little bit about how you how that worked,
how you got into that.
Speaker 4: Well, so the situation was that
that nobody really understood what was there.
It was sort of a state secret.
The oil industry was a state secret.
You know, all these big companies were not
known to the Russians.
And the Russians had these these vouchers.
They call them privatization certificates,
and they could invest their vouchers and whatever
they wanted to invest them in or sell their
vouchers.
And most Russians didn't really think that
their vouchers would be worth anything.
And so they sold them for a bottle of vodka
and and various people were buying up vouchers.
And this voucher exchange exchanges formed.
And and I did the math and I said, OK, if
you buy shares and some of these oil companies,
you're buying oil and like 10 cents per barrel
of oil reserves in the ground.
And at the time, oil prices were, let's say,
trading at thirty dollars and so 10 cents
on the ground versus thirty dollars out of
the ground, that that kind of had to be a
good deal.
And so I tell you the truth, it was it was
really hard to get people interested in the
West in that I would say, look, you know,
these things are trading in a ninety nine
point nine percent discount.
And most people, when they heard the word
Russia, they ran for the hills.
And so it wasn't like this was something that
was like a slam dunk obvious to most people.
Most people said, well, you know, whatever
the valuations are, I don't want to go anywhere
near Russia.
Speaker 1: So ultimately, you fell out of
favor in Russia and ultimately were even expelled
from the country.
Legal problems.
What what went wrong?
How did the problem start to develop?
Speaker 4: Well, so the companies that I ended
up becoming the largest foreign investor in
Russia, we had four and a half billion dollars
invested in all these companies.
And what I discovered was all the companies
were basically being robbed blind by these
oligarchs who were the majority shareholders.
And so I decided to try to start fighting
the thievery that the robbing of these companies
by exposing it.
And in doing so, you know, in these dictatorships
and third world countries, business and politics
are all sort of intertwined.
So the moment that I started exposing all
these nasty things going on, all of a sudden
the politics got involved and I was expelled
from the country.
I was declared a threat to national security.
My offices were raided.
They seized all of our documents.
And the next thing we knew, those documents
were used to.
Perpetrator, a highly complex fraud, where
they then stole our companies and used those
companies to steal two hundred and thirty
million dollars of taxes that my company had
paid to the Russian government.
And so it was all politics, mixed with business,
mixed with criminality.
And I was on the receiving end of all of that
stuff.
Speaker 1: Right.
So people may or may not know, but Russia
is a huge country.
It has extremely rural areas and those rural
areas have courts.
And often those courts are operating under
the direction of who knows who in power, bribes,
corruption, etc..
Talk a little bit about how that all worked.
I mean, that that was really the basis for
how these assets and companies were taken
from you.
Speaker 4: Yes, the Russians are very formalistic
plates.
So so it's not like, I don't know, in Mexico
or I don't know where there's grab your stuff.
And that's and that's done in Russia.
Everything is sort of done with some kind
of pretense.
And so they'll go to the court and the court,
just the judge will make a decision to transfer
your assets to somebody else and you'll stamp
the stamp, the judgment.
And and so they love all this sort of procedural
bureaucratic stuff, even though you can just
unwind it and show that it's all been done
fraudulently.
And for some reason, that that doesn't even
if you can show has done fraudulent, that
doesn't bother them.
They can all just waive their court decisions
in the air based on a five hundred dollar
bribe they made to the judge.
And that's the order of magnitude, the bribes
that they probably had to make in order to
get these kinds of decisions through the courts.
Speaker 1: So you tell one story.
And the way I like to sort of when I when
I read a nonfiction book about something I'm
not already familiar with, I first don't look
up anything about it.
I just read the book and then I'll look up.
Well, what are the other perspectives about
it?
And after reading your book and hearing your
story, did doing some research as well for
this interview, I come across allegations
that you were not actually the victim, but
you actually were the perpetrator.
In other words, you use the systems that you
criticize and say that victimized you to actually
participate in the corruption and in the fraud.
Now, it's beyond my ability to adjudicate
these things independently.
In the context of this interview, you tell
one story.
There are others who tell another story.
But what do you make of the fact that there
are these counter allegations that have been
made that say you are actually the perpetrator
here, are not the victim?
Speaker 4: Well, I mean, first of all, those
allegations were made by the people who stole
the money.
And so so we have we have a and just so you
know, in in Russia, this is what they do.
They shoot down a plane going over Russia
and they blame it on me, on the people who
are on the plane or I mean, everything is
the other guys did it.
And in our case, it's the whole thing is sort
of completely absurd from top to bottom.
The money was stolen in so so our companies
were stolen and all of these sort of messianic
machinations were done in 2000, in December,
like October, December of twenty seven.
And we filed a criminal complaint with with
all the major Russian law enforcement agencies
after we learned about the theft of our companies.
And we put that onto the record.
And three weeks after we filed the complaint,
the tax money was stolen, the two hundred
and thirty million dollars of taxes that we
paid.
And so what what criminals would file a complaint
about their upcoming crime before they committed
it?
I mean, there are so many errors in their
story.
They also blame the story that they say that
that Sergei Magnitsky, my dead lawyer who
was killed, by the way, for disclosing this,
they say he stole the money and he did it
together with another dead guy.
And the other dead guy died two, two months
before the crime was committed.
And so, I mean, just, you know, these guys
were like Keystone cops when it comes to coming
up with a conspiracy theory to blame the other
guy.
Speaker 1: So there have been multiple red
notices placed against you.
For people who don't know what a red notices,
a red notice is sort of a global Interpol
arrest warrant or arrest directive in a sense.
And there were ultimately Interpol decided,
as you tell in the book, not to enforce that
red notice.
They decided this is politically motivated,
this is bogus, and they decided not to enforce
it.
But there was a period of time where, as far
as you knew, if you had an interaction with
customs or border authorities in any number
of countries, you could have been arrested
and then extradited to Russia.
And then who knows what would have happened.
How long was that period of time where that
was a concern for you or you didn't know what
would happen?
Speaker 4: Well, so the book I finished reading
the book in 2014 and the first Interpol notice
from Russia came in 2013.
The second one came in 2013.
And since the book was written, there have
been eight Interpol notices for my arrest
from Russia.
And so when you say how long, there's been
numerous periods of time a week here, two
weeks there, three weeks where where if I
cross the border, I would be arrested, sent
to Russia to my death.
And I was arrested.
In May of 2013, I was traveling to Madrid
to meet with the Spanish anti-corruption prosecutor
to share information about Russian money laundering
connected to the murder of my lawyer, Sergei
Magnitsky.
And as I was walking out of my hotel room
before my meeting with the Spanish prosecutor
to Spanish national policemen arrested me
on a Russian Interpol warrant.
And it was only because I was allowed to pack
my bags in my hotel room before they took
me away, that I tweeted out that I was being
arrested and then all hell broke loose with
journalists and activists and everybody else
calling Interpol, calling the Spanish government,
calling everybody else so that by the time
I got to the police station, I was released.
But this kind of stuff is pretty scary and
it continues to wake me.
Up until today, the Russians are after me.
They've issued they've found me guilty twice
in their courts in absentia and have sent
me sends me to 18 years in prison.
I'd be killed if I went back there, no question.
Speaker 1: Yeah.
You you know, what's interesting is you talk
in the book about how something that Vladimir
Putin will do sometimes when he's asked about
individuals that are his adversaries and this
this happened with you.
He won't say the person's name.
And so there was an event you describe in
the book where Vladimir Putin was asked about
you and he referred to you, I think, as like
the gentleman you're referring to when I was
watching recently, the Biden Putin press conference
that took place after their meeting and Putin
was asked about Navalny by a journalist, it
was almost verbatim what was said to you.
Putin didn't say his name and said something
like the person you're referring to, I believe,
has committed crimes in our country, which
was I mean, that's essentially the same language
you describe, is it not?
Speaker 4: But he used that language about
me on a number of occasions.
But but here's here's the interesting thing.
So after the Magnitsky Act was passed and
just for your listeners, the Magnitsky Act
is a piece of legislation named after my lawyer.
Sergei Magnitsky was murdered after uncovering
this.
Two hundred and thirty million dollar tax
fraud that these criminals and corrupt officials
committed.
The Magnitsky Act was put in place in the
United States and other countries, which freezes
the assets and bans the visas of Russian human
rights violators.
Putin got so angry about the Magnitsky Act
that he banned the adoption of Russian orphans
by American families.
He made it the single largest foreign policy
priority to repeal the Magnitsky Act.
Even since an Italian vessel, Niscayah, Russian
lawyer to Trump Tower to meet with Donald
Trump Jr., Paul Manafort and Jared Kushner
before Trump was elected to say if he's elected,
please were.
The Magnitsky Act.
But here's here's the crux after the Magnitsky
Act was passed, he he got he had lost his
he gets so upset with me that my name is now
mentioned by Vladimir Putin.
And in fact, he mentioned it very profoundly
when he met with Trump and Putin, met with
Trump at the Helsinki Summit.
And at the end of the summit, there was this
question about whether the US, whether Russia
would hand over the 12 GRU officers who hacked
the election.
And Putin said we will hand them over if Trump
hands over Bill Browder.
Speaker 1: Bill, I so appreciate your time
today.
The book is Red Notice.
Bill Browder is the CEO of Hermitage Capital
Management and also head of the Global Magnitsky
Justice Campaign.
Really appreciate your time today.
Speaker 4: My pleasure.
Great to see you.